let's continue with the view because
then they started talking about
California the presidential race and oh
God here we we are back it's September
we're back go
but the question is who would you put in
there if Biden decides to get out of the
race for some whatever reason he comes
up with well I don't think he's going to
get out don't answer like a republican
it was okay I don't think it's not going
to happen but I would hope that the
Democrat the Democratic party would uh
rally around the vice president Kamala
Harris yeah where they've rallied around
Joe Biden but if not I think Gavin
Newsom is uh he's he's responsible for
one of the largest economies in our
country if not because California is in
trouble all the time with a lot of
homeless and a lot of problems but they
have a lot of good programs when it
comes to climate change they have great
they have great programs in terms of job
opportunity they're doing uh they have
great programs in terms of housing
they're addressing medicines
uh there is so much there my pen almost
broke in the middle of that okay so
first off uh I want to give Joy Behar
credit I try to give credit where credit
is due
uh Sonny says Gavin Newsom California
it's great he should be president
basically right because somehow Kamala
is not going to end up president like
it's just not going to happen the
country will not Rally around her the
Democrats will not Rally around her the
only way they rally around her is if
they realize she is just full on 100
hermetically sealed puppet right like
that's the only way no one is handing
the nuclear codes to this woman it's
already hilarious or scary as if that uh
that Joe's got him in the first place
but putting aside Kamala for a sec when
when Sonny says Gavin Newsom Joy has
like a moment of Sanity that California
does have problems economic problems and
it has homeless problems well I can't I
can't believe it should we send Joy
something we should send Joy a bottle of
something whatever she's drinking I feel
like she's a white wine spritzer lady uh
she actually addresses that and then and
then Sonny what does she say well Gavin
newsom's responsible for one of the
largest economies which he has as tanked
California basically has the highest
taxes in the country it's always
fighting with New York on who's going to
have higher taxes uh basically the most
regulation in the country so small
businesses don't want to start there
because you have to pay all of this
money to get your licenses to if you
want to build a home you have all of
these other regulations there's all of
this extra stuff that makes you as a
person who wants to be functional and
productive it makes your life basically
a living hell to accomplish anything so
okay they have a big economy because
California was the American dream Gavin
Newsom has been a large part of
destroying that thus for three straight
years now for the first time ever
California as you guys know has had a
net loss of population I've got four of
the people in this room right now who
all move to the free state of Florida
eventually also says that California has
great policies related to climate which
is just such a absolute
farce at every level putting aside that
the entire climate conversation is
complete nonsense the Earth is going to
be okay guys it really is the idea that
California or Gavin Newsom that they are
doing anything to save the environment
you know when we lived in California we
lived in LA and occasionally it would
rain fire once or twice a year it would
literally rain fire and there would be
massive fires burning all over the place
why didn't Gavin Newsom Stop Those fires
why doesn't Gavin Newsom stop the the
earthquakes I mean it's just such BS and
the idea that even if you 100
believed in man-made climate change that
Gavin Newsom could fix it my God just
incredible
foreign